the nissan micra also badged as the
march has been a popular choice for
buyers around the globe for over three
decades
to date some six million have been sold
making the super mini one of nissan's
top three car models
so the renault subsidiary is pinning its
hopes on the new micra to help it stay
in the black
our car tester tanju gang says the mikra
used to be a real woman's car cute and
cuddly now in its fourth generation it
yearns to be a global car and pleased
people from thailand to mexico tanshu
feels that in doing so it sacrificed
some of its charm
but with its curves this little runabout
is still an eye-catcher and popular with
the ladies unlike their predecessors
fourth generation micros are all
four-door models and therefore more
practical
engine range has shrunk no diesels are
on offer but there's a 1.2 liter three
cylinder gasoline-powered model which
comes in 59 kilowatt and 72 kilowatt
versions he's testing the 72 kilowatt
one
a supercharger helps the little engine
generate the additional 13 kilowatts of
output but does greater power also mean
greater fuel consumption not here the
more powerful engine actually uses 0.7
liters less gas per 100 kilometers so
it's too bad that it's only available
with more deluxe trim levels like the
acenta which costs upwards of fifteen
thousand eight hundred seventy euros in
germany
kanju says the nissan micra isn't a huge
car so it's a bit cramped in the back
but he notes that in a super mini you
can't expect much space
the equipment in the micra's interior is
pretty basic
after the dashboard display greets the
driver it helps him or her save gas by
displaying the current fuel mileage
optional extras include a sat nav for
750 euros and automatic climate control
for 400 euros
seats are slightly hard and don't offer
any lateral support but the trunk boasts
enough cargo volume to meet the average
person's daily needs
our tester says the base model micro
with the vizia first trim level which
costs around 11 and a half thousand
euros in germany is basically fine but
to get an audio system and a manually
operated climate control unit you'll
have to cough up 1500 euros more he
thinks that's a lot as the same package
in the smart 4-4 costs 1100 euros and
the climate controls automatic
but otherwise the nissan micra has
everything as super mini should thanks
to its lightweight construction it's
thrifty and agile
it offers good visibility yet is small
enough to make its way through the
narrowest of alleys so it's likely that
in future the number of microbuyers will
surpass the six million mark but the vw
polo and opal corsa still outdo the
nissan micra for workmanship